ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show uh this week and you know
it's like it's I don't usually we're
never serious on the show but I want to
be serious right now about an issue that
I think is kind of pervasive in our
culture and it's anti-semitism
and it's and the reason that I'm talking
about it is because it's everywhere you
look everywhere you look there is
anti-Semitism in this country it's not
just Kanye West
um you know it is everywhere it's in
invasive
it's in endemic is that what I want to
say but what I'm what I'm saying is
can can we take one example
can we take one example right now
the vitriol being directed
at Sam bankman freed
the utter
hatred
being directed at a young
man
who decided
that he wanted to change the world
and everybody hates him because he's
Jewish
that to me is a big problem and maybe
it's not a big problem to you it's a
huge problem to me
and I think if we don't call that out
like as someone with a platform if I
don't call that out and say stop that
now
if I don't if that's not called out what
happens then the next Sam bankman freed
the next young boy who dreams of setting
up an office offshore in another country
to run a cryptocurrency
trading empire
so that he can give Joe Biden money
will not do it
because we've killed that dream that
lives in that in that young boy's head
why because we hate
because we don't like people
take a look at this article here crypto
Nomads surfing the world for risk and
profit
a new and this is in the New York Times
this is the paper of record they do the
work they it's called due diligence they
do it
and they do it because they care and
they care because it's their reputation
that's at stake
crypto Nomads surfing the world for risk
and profit
how sexy a new generation of Industry
leaders has set up offshore trading
exchanges largely beyond the reach of
American regulators
[Music]
it's just after midnight in Hank on Hong
Kong and Sam Beckman freed stares at the
trading data on his six monitors
watching a global cryptocurrency crash
happen in real time
Mr bankman freed a 29 year olds from
California often Works Around the Clock
as he was that may evening he naps on a
bean bag set up by his computer a folded
up blanket sits on the floor he's worth
at least 8 billion on paper
that is even after the downturn started
in the spring where total Global losses
and the value of all cryptocurrency
eventually dropped 1.3 trillion and Mr
bankman freed saw it play out he knew
business played a role in the collapse
most of his customers are betting on
future crypto currency prices
fluctuations rather than buying and
selling Bitcoin they are borrowing to
make those bets even bigger it's a risky
approach but it can generate big wins
now bitcoin's value is dropping way down
crushing the highly leveraged bats of
bullish Traders on FTX and other
exchanges and forcing sales of their
position and wave after wave of account
liquidation these four sales were
helping undermine cryptocurrency prices
in terms of price movements the biggest
part of its liquidations he wrote to the
New York Times on May 24th from Hong
Kong this is precisely the type of
situation that U.S Regulators have tried
to avoid by prohibiting cryptocurrency
exchanges like FDX from selling
high-risk Futures to non-professional
investors in the United States and why
Mr bankman freed moved to Hong Kong
as he wanted to offer these products
called derivatives he's a crypto Nomad
one of the group of Industry leaders who
once lived in the U.S or Canada and have
since set up companies with basis of
operations that are to some degree
beyond the reach of American regulators
he's a nomad he's funny he's exciting
it's new it's sexy
there was an article about him I was
reading that we're talking about that he
was that how um how nice it was uh that
he was you know he was really into
giving Sam backman free this is true he
wanted to help people he wanted to help
poor people he wanted to help Democrats
he want he gave money to people and he
was a big he was the second or first or
second biggest donor to Joe Biden's
presidential campaign and he he really
wanted to change the world okay right
here Sam bankman freed the crypto whale
who wants to give billions away
stop being mean to it this is nuts like
many people in crypto see embankment and
by the way folks this is just um this is
just a great lesson if you're very
wealthy and you're doing the wrong thing
Bill Gates him all you have to do is
pretend to give money in charity
and it's it's a tax like there's the
whole charity scam is set up to service
wealthy people and it's to try to
launder not only their money but also
kind of their image and everything and
we might go into that uh in another
episode more is specifically intricately
because there are things that are very
interesting about how that's done
but for right now just let's just
understand as you know you're a smart
audience we understand that like when
you go out there and say I want to give
everybody there's a reason that you're
doing it and the reason is because
you're sinning or you're you're trying
to cover something up okay but this was
a real and by the way so the auditory as
soon as you say you want to end world
hunger or to the climate change or
vaccines everyone gets a vaccine as soon
as you go with that stuff where you look
this climate's [ __ ] up no we're gonna
fix it and there's never gonna be
another drought and as soon as you get
on that then you become an activist
billionaire and we love an activist
there's nothing better than a
billionaire with a heart of gold with a
conscience they want to help because
they look around and they're like have
any more Yachts can I buy I know I would
have had Greenhouse what about bees
where a bees should there be more bees
bees disappear I'll make them reappear
uh because they get a God complex these
people I would be much more comfortable
if they just bought Yachts I'm much more
comfortable but after a while they go
well yeah I get all board with the
Penthouse Apartments
and uh so what they really want to do is
they want to try to control the way you
live this is what a lot of them do
they're people on the right do it the
people on the left do it Peter Thiel
does it on the right when he funds all
these candidates to go out and uh win
elections he's got four billion dollars
but he's not Elon Musk is not happy with
money he's uh buys Twitter and he's on
Twitter all day wants attention on
Twitter and I'm not saying you know he's
doing some some stuff that needs to be
done and show you know bringing certain
things to the light and some things that
maybe don't need to come to the lighter
still coming but he you know it's the
idea that money doesn't really solve it
for these people they just they're not
done with you
that's the thing even after they've made
their money they're not done with you
it's not enough it's not enough that
their names are on the colleges uh or on
the Arenas or the David Koch the Lincoln
Center it's not enough that they've put
their names on every cultural and event
space anywhere it's not enough that
their names are on schools it's not
enough that they they are not done with
you they want more of a role in your
life the choices that you make and
that's why a lot of them start doing
this and bangmon freed to his credit
started early he started immediately
right here
unlike most people in crypto though he's
building up a fortune in order to give
half of it away this 28 year old has
amassed a 10 billion fortune in just
three years in the industry unlike most
people in crypto He is building a
fortune in order to get half of it away
an effective altruist he's essentially
robbing from the rich via his
preternatural crypto trading strategies
in order to give to the poor
maybe without the robbing party says LOL
in the end my goal is to have as much
impact as I can however that is
and right now I think that's flowing
through donation so figuring out how I
can be able to make as much money as I
can and donate as much as I can that's a
great sentence make as much money as I
can
and donate as much as I can
SPF as he sometimes referred to has been
walking the walk for some time now he
spent a couple of months as a director
of development for the center of
effective altruism in 2017 set up by the
CIA and before that he gave half of his
income during his stint on Wall Street
he plans on giving away around 50
percent of his crypto billions too but
only after he's finished reinvesting in
his ever expanding Empire well ain't
that the truth only after he's finished
reinvesting in his ever expanding Empire
he donates the causes as they come up he
was the second largest donor to
presidential Biden's campaign after
Michael Bloomberg
I was excited about the impact it might
have I basically thought it mattered
what happened in the election
so he this guy Sam bankman freed
and his girl has flipped on him by the
way this hussy
has flipped
can we get a picture this woman up
because this is why you do it right for
the puss
let's get a picture of this hottie up
what is 32 billion Buy in the market of
[ __ ] I don't like [ __ ] I don't even
know
I could get a real [ __ ] for 36 billion
dollars you know the [ __ ] that I could
get I mean it would be massive it would
it would be it would look like one of
those uh Florida uh mailboxes that are
shaped like a manatee
that's the [ __ ] I could get a [ __ ] 20
year old lacrosse player massive dick
that was always hard that's what you
could get for 32 billion and the gay
Market what is the straight Market get
you for
oh
Sam Sam Sam Sam Sam Sam
Sammy boy Sammy boy God damn it it was
for this
this is what it was for
the lying the cheating the sleeping on
the bean bag living in Hong Kong
evading U.S Regulators this is what it
was for and she's flipped and by the way
I'm not trying to
he's a lovely looking woman
but
what I'm saying here
it she'll slept better there but it
let's just say hey now
um I know that I'll be a um people will
be like well you're making fun of the
way a woman okay they're criminals who
stole everyone's money okay so maybe
that is that okay now
um they're they committed crimes and
they stole the money and she's ugly
and he got fat he would have been
slightly better looking but he put on
weight
foreign
dumplings and stealing now listen so
Carolyn Carolyn Caroline Carolina what's
her name Caroline Ellison Caroline
Ellison get her up she was in New York
City she's meeting with Regulators she's
flipping on this man who all he did is
try to change the [ __ ] world all this
guy did was try to change the world and
this woman Caroline Ellison the 28 year
old CEO of doomed crypto firm Alameda
research is facing scrutiny not only
over the firm's multi-billion dollar
melt meltdown but over rumors that she
the ex-girlfriend of Sam bankman freed
um is potentially going to flip Ellison
and backman freed were part of a cabal
of Roommates based in a luxury Penthouse
in the Bahamas that were behind the
scenes the machinations of FTX and
Alameda according to a bombshell report
by coindesk Alameda was one of about 130
FTX group Affiliates included in the
chapter 11 bankruptcy filing next week
so they were [ __ ] and I think they
had like a little [ __ ] party
happening like I believe and by the way
sorry after we look at this can we admit
to ourselves what happens when you get
Jeffrey and just laying out of the game
and now we have this and now we have
this they're ugly
I mean he's trying to be Jeffrey Epps I
mean Christ Almighty
relationships between the group of 10
insiders weren't strictly business
members of the Indian Circle are or used
to be paired up in romantic
relationships with each other the report
said so this is a crypto [ __ ] dungeon
that all these people are a part of the
whole operation was run by a gang of
kids in the Bahamas that would do
anything for each other
um let's take a look at Carolyn Ellison
here uh speaking she says something or
other I've never heard her speak but she
was just seen in a coffee house in New
York City they think she's going to flip
she's going to sell this man I mean what
is love about
think about it you what is love you fall
in love with someone
you move to the Bahamas with them you're
living in a luxury thing
it's it's hot you're having sex all the
time
um you're out
with each other you're maybe engaging in
orgies I don't know I'm just guessing he
gets a few more hotties like her and
they do a real it's a it's a real you
know they run a [ __ ]
like a real you know I don't even know
what you'd call it but it's hot to to
that to them it's hot and and you're
stealing from all these people but
you're not but you think but you are
you're diverting the [ __ ] FDX to
Alameda we know we'll go into the we'll
go into the technical aspects of it more
but this is about personality the world
is really about people and personalities
who do these [ __ ] up things so he's
trying to get laid he finds uh this lady
and they find a bunch of other nerd and
this by the way this shows you like
people that are really bad looking can
really do harm and especially women and
I don't mean this to be negative but
women who are not I mean I mean like
women that are not attractive a lot of
times unless they're brilliant or have
another skill they end up doing some
really heinous stuff and men who are
unattractive as well do very bad things
but it's I don't know there's just
something I've met on attractive men who
who kind of live a Pious life and women
that are unattractive can live a Pious
life too but some of them like I mean
this broad I mean and I'm not blaming
her but I'm saying that like this is
what happens when you want to be hot and
you can't be hot what happens is
you somehow lose 32 billion dollars for
people
so let's see what she says I don't even
know what she's talking about here
a lot of like a elementary school math
being comfortable with risk yeah that's
very important suck my [ __ ] pretend not
to have things like suck my face
in your mouth necessarily great risk
management tools are you wet right now
what
I want to put my coffee well I probably
don't want to go into specifics too much
specific you're a [ __ ] you're a dirty
little Lord
what a what a fun orgy they had huh
these are fun orgy people athletic
greens is the best everybody loves it
with one delicious scoop of athletic
creams you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Foods super
sauce superfoods probiotics adapted
agents to help you start your day right
it's better than coffee it doesn't make
you crash this special blend of
ingredients supports your gut health
your nervous system your immune system
your energy recovery focus and aging all
the things I love it I consume it it
gives me the energy to do these shows
Rogan takes it all my friends take it
the taste is great I send it to family
and friends they love it I bring it with
me when I travel when I do shows it's a
big energy performance I have to have
the energy to do podcasts I'm all about
athletic greens everybody I know takes
it many people I know are strong and
athletic they're Olympians they run and
swim and fence
it's a lifestyle baby that's the
difference here I'm telling you it is
something that really isn't uh you're
not gonna find it anywhere else athletic
greens is a climate neutral certified
company 2020 AG purchase carbon credits
with support projects protecting old
growth rainforest for every purchase we
donate to organizations helping to get
nutritious food to kids in need
including no kid hungry here in the U.S
how cool is that in 2020 athletic greens
donated 1.2 million meals to kids in
2020 to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticqueens.com Tim Dillon again
that's athleticqueens.com Jim Dillon to
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
Insurance well SPF now have you heard of
this which I don't like I don't like
this because this guy I don't think he
deserves it I don't think he deserves
what's happening to him I don't I think
uh he should be
um
let out
and
giving us like a Stern talking to you
but then freed
um and given a six-month ban from
Trading but then you know no uh he's in
a roach and rodent infested jail in the
Bahamas by the way even the [ __ ]
press like feels bad for him like George
Stephanopoulos is like you only have a
hundred grand you only have 100 Grand in
your account and uh and uh spf's like
he's like yeah I only have 100 Grand and
George Stephanopoulos is like I can't
imagine going from 32 billion to 100
Grand it's like George how about can you
imagine ripping everyone off can you
imagine that like it's the the way that
he's been dealt with kind of with the
kid gloves and the way that it's been
all very light touch well he's made
mistakes
there's been mistakes made it's a
meltdown not a ponzis it's a meltdown
it's a horrible meltdown that he just I
mean he was there
but he's made mistakes
he's troubled
his company is and you know instead of
you know the words that you're not
really hearing are like Thief
embezzle in a Ponzi ski like liar you're
not hearing those as much but you are
hearing like troubled and you know he
was just this crypto crash and he was
you know so let's take a look at the
prison that he is in this guy is in a
jail in the Bahamas that is so bad and
he's a vegan and his parents have been
petitioning like please let him eat
because vegans don't eat animal products
if you uh don't know that already
vegans are you know so Sam bankman
Freed's family reportedly called prison
to request vegan meals they called up
hello it's Miss Friedman and there she's
afraid and she's a Stanford and the
father is at Stanford and they're
professors
and uh
and uh they called the jail and they
were like Sam does not eat bacon or eggs
or meat at all or fish
he must have vegetables spring rolls
with peanut dipping sauce and you have
to bring in his girlfriend Carolyn to
simulate him with a finger
it does not look nice this gel does not
look nice but I'm telling you right now
to be honest with you
what is jail really supposed to look
like right I mean he's there until he
can
be killed
by no he's that people say oh is he
going to be Epstein I'm like I don't
think he's going to be Epstein what does
he really know I don't think he knows
much
I think it's just an like uh maybe he
does and then he will but I don't think
he like I don't think he's got people
like that like Epstein had files on P he
had videos of people I don't think Sam
bankman freed has not uh and he's
disposable like the Democratic party
will I don't know that they'll
maybe you'll get a sweetheart deal but
they'll just throw him into the street
like they did remember Christine blasey
Ford she came out and she was like the
Supreme Court Justice judge Kavanaugh he
was uh you know he [ __ ] jumped on me
at a party and it's sexually assaulted
me remember her and then that didn't
work and he got confirmed anyway they
were like well good luck sister like
they throw you in the street they don't
care so what happens is at the end of
the day
you know he's probably going to go down
for this I would imagine unless his
lawyer they're setting it up already
with the lawyers like it's all about
intent he didn't intend for this to
happen but then I think they're going to
prove that actually he did he actually
he actually uh he did or he was taking
the type of risk where it was quite
obvious what would happen if
he continued doing what he was doing he
was arrested on multiple charges
stemming from allegations that he
deceived FTX customers and investors he
was arrested this week
um he tried to get bail they wanted 250
000 bail for him and he they the judge
was like no you don't get it and he's
like but I'm a vegan and the judge is
like you still can't have it he goes but
I don't eat meat judge goes I get it you
still can't leave you're a Flight Risk
he's like but any animal products any of
them I can't eat any of the judge I get
that the chief magistrate said Mr
brankman Freed's access to financial
resources made his risk of fleeing so
great that he had to remain Behind Bars
on Tuesday his fate was in the hands of
a judge in the Bahamas who oversaw a
hearing
a shoeing as usual disheveled outfit of
shorts hit a t-shirt because he was like
the cash crypto guy he was always casual
he was always in like sure it's a hoodie
he always looked like he smelled bad his
hair was crazy and that was I guess it
was like a power thing for him he's like
yeah dude I'm like a nomad I'm a crypto
Nomad look at this [ __ ] look at my
[ __ ] I'm a crypto Nomad we live in
countries without Regulators we [ __ ]
shower when we want and we [ __ ] trade
um so he shows up in a suit to this
and um at the end as the courtroom was
cleared his parents who also live in
like a 10 million home I think he bought
them in Bahamas uh they gave him a long
hug
and uh
yeah it's sad it's sad because
should vegans even go to jail
I mean when you think about it should
someone who doesn't consume animal
products a Humane person a person who's
Humane and that's why he doesn't consume
milk
because it was taken from an animal
against their will
and he doesn't he's not inhumane and so
why would a person like that and his
only thing was he
he took like 32 billion dollars of
somebody else's money a lot of other
people's money but those are people
they're not animals and he's so kind by
not eating um you know the bacon that I
don't even know if he should go to jail
like why would even go to is his [ __ ] a
vegan
because if I catch her with a [ __ ]
Bond me she's going to the chair uh and
she's flipping by the way get her up
she's flipping Carolyn Allison is
flipping the love affair is over the
hots Bahamian sex is over now she's
going to put the nails in his coffin as
the way to save her self
she's the way to save herself because at
the end of the day you know in these
situations which is why it is very tough
when you are [ __ ] somebody and and
and running a Ponzi scheme with them you
have to really be tight
and you have to kill them if you get
caught he should have killed her
because one of the people disappeared
from FTX one of these guys Mr Wang was
his name uh a guy disappeared and no one
can find him and then this other guy
Nish who also disappeared they got out
but the people will find them probably
um
but FDX should have poisoned this woman
sambachman freed SPF sorry I said FDX
that's the company SPF is the man now he
should have poisoned this now people are
saying to me Tim this is not nice to say
I understand that people are upsetting
me when I give real politics when I give
advice for the real the real of the real
being on the streets being real not
putting on the show
poison her you should have poisoned her
you need
to poison her
and
um
you know
she just got found they found her in a
coffee house in New York City and
she's there and she's getting coffee and
a Twitter user put it up and the and the
Barista said this is her this is
Caroline and a lot of people are
speculating well what you doing in New
York what you doing is she hanging out
she trying to make it on Broadway
no she's flipping you've seen billions
you know how it works she's flipping
there's there's men in cheap suits
they're the feds and she's sitting there
saying everything about this is a man
who's come she's swallowed and as she's
telling the feds he's a criminal
it's not right it's it's frankly not
right
it's not right
Carolyn Ellison likely working with FEDS
against Sam bankman freed
sandbagman Freed's reported
ex-girlfriend was likely among the first
people to turn on him and help
prosecutors build their fast-moving
fraud case in the Epic 8 billion plus
collapse of FTX cryptocurrency exchange
a former U.S government lawyer said
Wednesday
Allison 28 is a key figure in the case
as she was the one-time CEO of Alameda
research hedge fund which authorities
claim received billions of dollars that
bankman free diverted from FTX
the speed of the indictment and the
breadth of the charges against bankman
freed meant quote someone relatively
senior in the command is cooperating
with Federal authorities in exchange for
leniency for their own potential
misconduct
you know you think you know somebody you
think you know somebody and you give
them the chance
to be part of your Bahamian crypto sex
call and their their their thank you is
to flip and this probably hurts him
he's probably hurt by this and for that
I am sorry and for that I am sad because
at the end of the day so we're going to
follow the story closely We're Not Gonna
OD on it
but we're gonna follow it closely
because it's got all the things we like
sex
fraud
and anti-Semitism fighting anti-semitism
because we don't want anybody to be
anti-semitic about this this is not
right that's why we think so we're here
on Guard we're here on watch
like tonight's watch from Game of
Thrones
don't even say it
yay
he's sitting in the back of the studio
that's why I keep pointing at him yay
I'm kidding I'm kidding freeze pie makes
a unique line of glass pieces that cool
cannabis Smoke by over 300 degrees
imagine smoother bigger clouds with any
uh without any of that chest or throat
burn finally no more coughing attacks no
more chugging water after every RIP just
joyous pipe and bong hits it don't hurt
your throat the secret is freezable
glycerin chambers that come on every
piece pop one of those chambers in the
freezer for a one hour and a smoke
passes through it's instantly cooled
through a dramatically smooth and chilly
hit treat yourself or be the holiday
hero with a gift they'll always remember
this is really cool for smokers it don't
want to hurt their [ __ ] throats
shot now and enjoy free shipping at the
freezepipe.com and use the code Dylan
for 10 off your entire order that's the
freeze pipe.com and use the code Dylan
for 10 off your entire order they
spelled it wrong is that the code that
is spelled wrong d-i-l-l-i-o-n
all right well then put that in see if
that works the perfect gift for your
home or your favorite sonar shop today
and smoke like royalty without paying a
king's Ransom
what Lauren bobert won her election in
Colorado that meth head and what's fun
about Lauren bobert is she really is
like this white trash Colorado kind of
lunatic whose husband
um was like uh there was a 9-1-1 call
which you should play where like the
neighbor was just asking the bobert kids
to calm down on their scooter I don't
know what where they live in Colorado I
imagine it's just um you know leather
face compound but the kids are speeding
up and down the street on scooters and
the neighbors go can you calm them down
this was from a while ago like can you
calm them down and then Lauren and her
husband now he's been arrested for
exposing himself to people she's been
arrested multiple times for fighting
with the cops she's a real goon and you
gotta respect it because it's the end of
America and why not have
uh Lauren bobert who's she's like a
common white trash
Denny's waitress and now she's in
Congress
and she's fought the cops if you look at
her rap sheet if she was black she would
have been shot 96 times in the back of
her head
as she ran away but because she's white
she's in Congress see that's a woke
point for all the people who look he's
actually right away actually you're not
listening
I'm all over the place but it's true I
look at a rap sheet and I'm like Jesus
Christ this woman has done some crazy
stuff let's play this 9-1-1 call but
it's authentic you know because these
are a lot of her people a lot of her
people and the issues that they face are
meth related
so to me like the fact that her and her
husband are just two local criminals
means they understand the constituency
they understand what motivates 911
what's the address of the emergency
repeat the address for me one more time
to make sure I have it correct
still Colorado
okay perfect
your phone number you're calling me from
sir
all right that's what we're showing here
as well tell me exactly what happened
there's a domestic situation happening
right in front of my driveway and now
it's he's driving away I think just
about fighting there's a
that that is Lauren bobert's jackass
husband Jason he's running over my
mailbox right now
you jackass
and he you said come on man what did we
do wrong I live here I didn't even talk
to me sir yes okay I need to be some
[ __ ] going down here okay okay who is
jackass husband Lauren Jason bobert
Jason what's he driving yeah Lauren
bobert the congresswoman he's driving a
Ford pickup F1 you're gonna kill people
her and her husband gonna shoot somebody
and the Republicans you have to be like
well you know we
charcoal
by the way there's no one the
Republicans will not
will not put up to if they get votes
there's no one the Republican party will
not put it put over they'll act crazy
when her husband and her shoot someone
by the way this will be so entertaining
but there's no way this does not end in
some type of like Ruby Ridge standoff
and the Republican party will just be
like you know you know you know I you
know we believe in democracy but I mean
her and her husband are just fun they're
just fun people and um yeah I mean she's
they're what they claim to be right
they're just kind of the it's from the
Christian meth contingent of uh that
state Colorado and people that are like
I believe in the Lord but also meth
and violence against others and it's
what it's what Jesus would want Jesus
would want to be
um Jesus would be Lauren bobert let's
see what Jesus would do let's get up
Lauren bobert's rap sheet and let's see
what kind of activities Jesus would do
if he was living in Colorado tending bar
which is where I imagine Jesus would
come back if Jesus came back he'd be
like L.A in New Yorker for [ __ ] and he'd
go to Colorado not Denver not Denver can
you [ __ ] he'd go to uh outside of
Colorado and 10 bar like she did for
years
um but there's a rap sheet
um for Lauren bobert
um yeah here we go Lauren bobert and her
husband racked up arrests in home
District okay the 34 year old lawmaker
who beat her districts very conservative
blah blah blah blah blah
um so I mean again Lauren bobert is one
of my favorite people and she is
[Music]
um
she is definitely responsible for
uh some Mayhem in her home state okay
bobert in 2015 was covered for
disorderly conduct at a country music
festival that's something Jesus would do
after police said she attempted to
interfere in the arrest of minors busted
for underage drinking that's what Jesus
would do now she's concerned about
minors all the time that they're getting
corrupted right so miners were being
busted for um in underage drinking and
Lauren bobert's attitude was like Hey
we're having fun it's the festival
finally Malone let him get [ __ ] up and
then she was cuffed
bobert said the revelers had not been
read their Miranda rights and that the
arrest was illegal so she's out there
helping drunk children
continue to get drunk we like that
Lauren continued yelling and causing the
underage drinkers to become unruly
that's when she realized she had a
future in politics when she was at the
Country Music Festival and she's uh
yelling at these child drunks and
they're going dead she's right I did
that she went I can win and I can be in
Congress now
Lawrence said multiple times that she
had friends at Fox News and that the
illegal arrest would be national news at
the time bobert was running Shooters
Grill in Rifle Colorado cannot make that
up is that really the name of it
well the story was
a year later in 2016 bobert was charged
with careless driving and operating an
unsafe vehicle After Rolling her truck
into a ditch again the Lord would do
this when she failed to show up to court
a month later a warrant was issued for
her arrest
she was booked on February 13 2017 she
ultimately pleaded guilty to the unsafe
vehicle charge and paid
123.50 and fines and costs the careless
driving charge was dismissed
so this is what Lauren bobert's up to
Lauren bobert's a wide lady so she
finally won her recount they had a
recount and
she finally won so now she is
representing Colorado
and Colorado
good for her drugs are all over the
country by the way and they're too you
know everybody's on drug you know I only
have a waiter the other day and I'm
telling you right now waiters when
they're not waiting tables
want to only be on on a amount of drugs
that is like terrifying like I don't
think people fully there's something
about that business I don't know what it
is where as soon as they get off as soon
as they're off of their shift they just
want to get
[ __ ] up to the point of death where
they don't know if they're coming back
they're on the edge there is Terence
McKenna would say maybe in the Bardo
whatever they're in that halfway between
being alive and being dead that's the
only time they can be happy there's
something about that job that makes
people just want to get really [ __ ] up
and I was hanging out with this dude and
he was like he's like yeah I'm a waiter
and he's a catering waiter there's
something that's even more intense about
them people that do catering parties
they go they travel they do these
catering part and after they do the
catering party they just want to do
heroin there's nothing I mean it's crazy
this is interesting article here why
waiters drink and why it matters
my former co-worker once drank so much
during a waitressing shift she stumbled
through the restaurant with her
intoxication on full display even the
chaos of the service Rush couldn't hide
the state she was in by closing she was
fired after work that night a group of
us consult her at the casino Sportsbook
where we often congregated for an
after-hours ritual over drinks ciggies
and video poker we traded our best War
Stories together our minds and bodies
recovered from the physical exhaustion
and emotional stress of service we told
our friend that everything would be fine
after all she wasn't the first employee
to be under the influence on the job
some bartenders taste tested enough
cocktails to maintain a steady Buzz
through their shifts we knew which
service cooks and managers relied on
cocaine to get through the Long Island
and this is true a friend of mine is in
the restaurant business and she's a junk
Box means she's a box of junk meaning
that she's what they call a garbage head
meaning she'll do it all anything
anything you put in front of a potion
pill powder she will snarf it down she's
like a Game of Thrones dragon just like
she really wants to be [ __ ] up all the
time there's some curse that these
people whatever it is I don't know what
it is there's some curse
about working in a restaurant or
catering
that if you have any predisp
predisposition to addiction like if you
have any if there's anything about you
that might want to get [ __ ] up well by
golly if you are a waiter or a waitress
you are going to end up smoking crack
because this is the way that they do it
I don't know what it is I don't know why
it is but this is just something and
this guy's a young dude we're talking he
goes yeah he's like you know we just we
take shrooms we do that and there's
nothing wrong with that but he was like
we do blow them on so many drugs he'll
text me sometimes he goes I'm on so many
drugs I'm on so many drugs right now I
go what but that's what he but he's a
waiter it's normal
you're the normal waiter it's not one of
those things that you know is
um looked down on in that profession
it's something that people actually like
they go this is not like I I guess in
crypto when you leave them when you set
up an office outside of America it's so
it's a well-established thing that you
do and when you're a waiter being on
your day off being so [ __ ] up
that you just text people I'm on so many
drugs right now is a normal occurrence
and I'm not I'm not judging it I'm just
saying it's it's interesting there's
certain jobs where people are really
really [ __ ] up all the time certain
jobs people get really really [ __ ]
wasted and certain jobs they don't
it's very interesting I don't know which
without Union representation these jobs
are usually accompanied by poor pay
inconsistent schedules and no medical
insurance High turnover means that when
substance abuse behaviors do interfere
with job performance workers can be
easily and immediately replaced it's
true it's a tough gig it's rough to be a
waiter or a waitress but some people do
it very well you know they have those
lifelong professional waiters that are
you know this is their entire job for
their entire life they do very well and
some of those people are in unions
it was just to the side it's just
something I wanted to discuss because it
is something interesting to me about
that particular professions where people
tend to use lots of drugs are always
interesting to me and it's not only
waiter don't it's not only a way to what
about all the cocaine on Wall Street why
are you just saying it's weird I was a
waiter and I never did drugs I can't see
my kids for other reasons
I'm just saying that it's it's curious
to me when I meet somebody who's on
crack and I go what do you do and
they're like a little later and you're
like God you people love it you just
love us drop the nose you love a key to
the nose is there anything wrong with
that you love to do you just love to
throw a spinach dip down on a table and
then put a key to your nose is that such
a big deal just admit it just admit it
admit it you like the sound of a crack
rock cooking on a spoon
and no one even does crack anymore it's
such a [ __ ] retro thing everybody's
on meth or pills nobody's on crack I saw
my doctor today I'm like does anyone
don't crack anymore he's like not really
have you been ordered your nicest here
well you might fool Santa but you
definitely can't fool your internet
provider they see all your late night
naughty searches this year but
expressvpn that's the move that's what
you got to give people this holiday
season private mode doesn't keep your
activity private your internet provider
like ATT or Verizon can see all the
websites you've clicked on expressvpn
all your traffic gets rerouted to an
encrypted server so all your browsing
activity stays between you and God
expressvpn's app works on all your
devices so whether you're on your phone
laptop uh tablet whatever you're
protected best of all expressvpn is
super easy to use all you have to do is
tap one button to turn it on and you're
instantly protected so take yourself off
the naughty list with the number one
rated VPN visit
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon to get three
extra months for free that's e x p r e s
s
vpn.com Tim Dylan I mean there's there's
lots of things number one it's the
holiday day so I do I want to wish
everyone including the bankman freed
family a happy holiday happy Hanukkah
whatever they celebrate I don't know
um but I I do think that it's important
for the holidays to realize
that it's it's a time to give as well as
get
and that's something that I've always
believed that it's a time to kind of go
out there and notice the people in your
community that are hurting
and give give to them
um and this is these are things that we
do
uh every year
every year I look around and I say who's
hurting who are the people who are the
people that need help and we try to help
them and
so what we want to do is we want to set
up a contest
where
it's called show us how bad you have it
now
it's it's it's it's it's not
it's it's going to be done in a very
dignified way all the things that are
wrong with your life
show us on camera how bad they are if
you get beat
I want to see you getting beat
I want to see you get knocked around
your house if your mother or father is
an alcoholic tape them very very quietly
because they might they get angry these
alkies but very very quietly when
they're in their chair and they're very
low and they're just and they're just
hitting it they're hitting it with the
bottle and they're hitting it real low
and slow and they're in their chair
maybe they're watching tuckies or maybe
Rachel mads it doesn't matter when
they're hitting it like
no no no
film them send it in
film them send it in
if members of your family are in the
hospital get to cat get the [ __ ]
camera out in the hospital show me them
show me them
show me them take the phone and show me
them show me the people in the hospital
bed show me them right now
if you got fired from your job prove
that to me if you're eating cat food I
want you on all fours eating it out
I with the phone and show me that to be
to be entered into our uh prize contest
prize for the holidays because we do
want to we do want to help people that
are hurting but we want to make sure
you're really hurting like you're
hurting
you're hurting
um if if something bad is that if your
mother or father has a terminally ill
disease and many people do and you're
caring for them
film that and send us in a um like it's
like what do they call it's like you
send us into submission but I want I
want it when it's bad
like when they're [ __ ] themselves at
the table be like be like be like be
like because you'll hear them in the
background they'll be like hey gosh hi
my name is Josh and I've been dealing
with my mother and her incontinence for
you hold on
I'm saying saying sending this to the
Tim Dylan show in the hopes and I win
your holiday giveaway and then you show
and you go like this you pan out and
then you see Mom and say she's [ __ ]
on the floor and then you yeah come have
me it's on the floor it's leaking it has
to be
that type of submission and again it's
only because
to be sure that you are genuinely
hurting genuinely hurting in a way that
makes us uncomfortable when we watch
the submissions that win are going to be
the ones where we can't get through them
if we can watch your full submission
you're probably not going to win I mean
it's got to be bad I'm talking about you
walk in and it looks like a normal house
and I'm like what's the problem here and
you go hey honey and you kiss your wife
and she kisses you and then you just
panel pan over to the bassinet and the
baby is all bones like
just a bony baby and you go oh our baby
has the Bony disease it's a skeleton and
it's like
and it's terrifying and you just poke it
with a stick a few times that's the type
of submission because we want to make
sure that you you are really a candidate
for help
you know what I mean don't hit us with
student loans if you do that I'll kill
you don't tell us about your student
loans tell us about
night terror I like a night terror
but a night terror where you get up and
get a knife and you're running around
like it's Gotta It's gotta take and
build build the submission build the
submission because we can't because
we're going to do 500 dollars
you will get 500 American dollars if you
can prove to me your life
is so bad and I mean bad in a way bad in
a way that I don't even frankly
understand it
I have to Google terms I have to
research how bad these things are uh to
give you 500 uh dollars we'll take taxes
out for us and then send it to you
we'll take it to Ed my tax rate not
yours I'm kidding of course we're not
doing that we're not giving anyone money
we don't care how bad it no uh we are
gonna do some charity stuff but
obviously uh we don't want submissions
please I know that is a joke I'm saying
that only because God help us many
people you would think many people would
go oh that's a funny bid he does uh but
this is actually not what he wants
because the last thing I want is anyone
out there to take this seriously and
many of you will many of you will I'll
get one from SBF he's like I'm in jail
hey Tim Dylan show it's SBF I'm in jail
eating meat
I'm in jail in the Bahamas eating meat
and all I want to do is eat my [ __ ]
girl's puss
all I want to go down is on her yeasty
pots
I mean listen this this job isn't always
dignified that I do what do you want me
to tell you it's not only dignified I
talked for 116 hours a year this is not
always didn't I'm not Charlie Rose here
we're trying to have a little fun he
boinked a dog he's not great himself
they're all gross and they robbed you
they took all your [ __ ] money so
we're gonna call them names and then he
tries to get out of jail because he's
[ __ ] vegan this is ridiculous they
should just be shot to be honest I'm not
even kidding like we tolerate this level
of fraud because we like it and because
we are a criminal country many people
believe they can pull this off and live
in the dream and now they're it's one
thing when they were hot they're gross
now the people who are robbing you are
gross
does that not make you [ __ ] mad
they should at least be hot they should
at least look like they should rob you
give me a six foot five guy and a chick
with big tits let them Rob we got gross
nerds robbing gross not even [ __ ]
cute nerds where you go yeah and [ __ ]
around with them for a little bit I mean
we're getting shellacked by beasts
it's wrong it's really wrong there
should be some hot people have the right
to pillage but not and ugly people have
the right to help hot people but
someone's got to be hot are you telling
me nobody in FDX was hot every single
one of them looked like a gym sock the
whole [ __ ] group get FTX up and hit
image there's got to be somebody that's
attractive there's got to be somebody
that's hot
foreign
rink folks it is beautiful don't go to
Rockefeller Center go to woman rank
go to woman rank ah
yeah it's just not it is it
Lord help us
what is that me over there they hired me
am I in this company
it's five Asians of me
he's the fact is the best looking guy
these aren't hot Asians these aren't
Premiere ages aren't top tier Asians
look at that guy in the left go up now
go up that first guy
I mean what is this what is that he's
like what's going on here
and then the fourth guy over he's like
he knows how [ __ ] they all are look at
him
some of these people disappeared look
who had disappeared at FTX this guy Wang
he got out of there I wonder which one
is Wang probably the white guy but he's
out of there one of the guys FTX is gone
he just disappeared like a thief in the
night
and it's unfortunate
um because some people need to they just
they they flee which I don't I guess SBF
couldn't really flee because they were
on them real quick like white on rice
but I imagine if he could flee he would
have fled
if he could have fled he would have fled
crypto billionaires would disappear and
casualties of the bear Market
I don't know if this is going to have it
there's good Google Google FTX Wang or
Nish
those were the guys and somebody some
they were they were saying how like
they're embarrassed and ashamed
yeah Gary Wang nishad here they are
the rallying Cry of the second scorned
crypto faithful
which started when FTX filed in a
bankruptcy has taken on added serious
after SPF was arrested but now we're
trying to find these other two cats Gary
Wang
okay
Gary Wang and uh who this guy I don't
know where he is where is Gary Wang
Gary Wang if you want to come on the Tim
Dillon show
Gary Wang is not like his co-founder SPF
who loves Fame and putting himself at
the center of public attention well Gary
Smart in fact his little public
information about Wang who has been
described as Shady but critical player
Wang Matt bankman freed in a math camp
in high school that's where it all
starts later they became College
roommates in the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology MIT do you know once I was
in an Uber and we went by MIT and I was
eating Me and Bobby Kelly got food above
his Bakery and I was eating this taste
as something called a chocolate bomb I
was just eating it it's just a big bowl
of chocolate I was just eating it and I
said the Uber driver I'm like that's MRT
and I was like my mouth is all full I'm
like they recruit a lot of NSA people
out of there and I'm like I don't go
there and then the Uber driver goes I
know he's like I know you don't go there
I was just eating the chocolate bomb
um Wang met Bank ref cap they got
degrees then they went to MIT before
co-founding Alameda research and later
FTX Wang worked at Google he claims we
built a system to aggregate prices
across public flight data according to
an introduction to da da da da
he started Alameda in 2017 Wang left at
Tech Giant Google
yeah I mean listen to everybody's like
where is Wang nobody knows where this
guy is in the aftermath of ftx's
collapse of the subsequent 400 million
dollar hack questions are circulating
around who could possibly have abused
client funds Wang is a prominent suspect
as one of the few people with quote root
access to exchange see these guys maybe
like a wang he might be able to just go
live in like a Thailand or so like go
off the map right but they I wonder what
countries go to the countries that have
non-extradition treaties with the United
States and I'm going to see and I'm
going to recommend Wang a place to live
non-extradition treaties with the United
States Wang if you're listening the Tim
Dillon show we have an eye for real
estate and an eye for luxury
they are Afghanistan
that's going to be a toughie
they're I'm telling you right now that's
tough
Ethiopia
yeah
Morocco's nice
Morocco could be nice to Vatican
Myanmar difficult they have like run by
Hunter I think they do the caning and
other things they do worse things
Vietnam they still don't like us but
Wang you might be able to pass
Yemen the Civil War nambia
Cuba
I think Morocco
is Beats out Mozambique it beats out
everything I think if you if you go to
either Morocco or the Vatican Wang if
you're listening if you can go to
Morocco get a nice [ __ ] beautiful
Moroccan Villa
and they won't extradite you
I mean we might go and kidnap you
Morocco is gonna go to Morocco homes for
sale right there
Marrakesh probably
a property for sale in Morocco you could
get a villa dude this guy can get you
can live like a king if I move to
Morocco I could live
like Sam bankman freed then not now
I mean you can live it up that's a villa
for under a million bucks in Morocco
boom boom
it's fine it's not great but it's better
than jail Boom Wang done Morocco and by
the way there's probably much more
beautiful
um
uh houses there too if you want to spend
real money but you probably want to keep
it low like you probably don't want to
spend an insane amount of money here you
go here's 20 million Marrakesh
I mean this is if you really wanna if
you really want to show off
which I don't know if you want to do
oh I mean that's nice
to own in Morocco I want to own in
Afghanistan
I want to own in Afghanistan go to
Afghanistan homes for sale I love real
estate and I love the idea of owning in
Afghanistan
and by the way I bet it's not as bad as
people think
I bet Afghanistan's coming back
it's like Detroit it's like on the way
back
Kabul two-room house for sale 1.2
million Afghan I don't know what that
means
show this show this listing
well I like this it's a little war-torn
but I like it
I like that they're showing you stains
stains on the on the floor on the
concrete on the stone
look at that that's nice where'd that
come from someone had got a talking to
let's keep looking at this this is kind
of nice and I don't know what 1.2
million Afghani is
go up a little bit that's a six bedroom
that'll give me some space I can put a
studio in it wow
not the worst
Maybe I'm Wrong about Baraka Wang
if you check out Kabul
that's fun you can trade
cryptocurrencies from there now
it's a lot going on here very busy
what is that is that a bathroom
power Jesus with a shower oh hold on so
the shower just you can shower while you
[ __ ]
in that bathroom you can literally
shower you could sit down to shed and
then I actually like that because
sometimes you're tired you don't want to
stand up you can sit down and [ __ ] and
then just tilt the shower to you so that
the shower hits you while you're
[ __ ] is that the worst thing in the
world
probably not
nice grand entrance way but this is
where you have to go if you trade
cryptocurrencies and you lose
everybody's money unfortunately you do
have to go to uh one of those
non-extradition treaty
countries Tim dilloncomedy.com New
Year's Eve folks we're gonna have so
much fun at Irvine uh the Irvine Improv
I hate uh the people there and I hate
the club
please buy a ticket and I'm kidding I
love the you know but let's be honest
every time I play there I want to kill
myself I want the audience I want sarin
gas to come in and kill the audience but
maybe this time it's the charm
um Irvine Improv timelinecomedy.com I'm
also at the spotlight casino out in
Indio let's buy some tickets there
because it's a very big casino and it's
out in the middle of nowhere make a trip
of it get some drugs get in the car make
a trip event stand up live in Phoenix in
February it's one of my favorite clubs
in the world I love stand up live I love
the the leathered uh people of Arizona
I'm gonna be up there doing lines of
coke with Carrie Lake
also
um I mean we've got all kinds of things
coming in Tucson's gonna happen I don't
even wanna there's so many things
happening Tim dilloncomedy.com you can
get your tickets to all of these
shows all of these shows
are available at timberlakecomedy.com
patreon.com for any bonus content you
want uh for the show and uh we will see
everybody next week stand by Sam bankman
freed
if you're if you're doing a scam with
your woman right now you better look at
her and you and that [ __ ] better come
to an understanding because when [ __ ]
goes south when [ __ ] goes left
she can't be [ __ ] flipping on you
poison or hey Sam Beckman freed can you
have somebody get to her
these guys are such amateurs also Putin
I think is nuking us next week that's
what the that's what a I think I read an
article that literally said we're being
nuke next week I think it's like on the
I think it's like on his schedule I
think it's on Putin's calendar right now
to just nuke us like on Wednesday so
hopefully we get something done before
that but
tonight